[Aplausos]
hola nos veo a ninguno así que necesito
iros por lo menos voy a decir
y que me vais a contestar vale a ver
vamos a hacer la prueba
sí no
pero yo
perfecto estamos sintonizados perfecto
bien pues os voy a contar algo que
quería compartir con vosotros imaginad
tren barcelona-valencia de los antiguos
emprende estos vetusto hay varios que
volvía de hacer una ponencia en un
congreso y nada me toca el acento del
pasillo y a los pocos minutos bien un
chico joven de 20 y pocos con dejar sus
cosas en el portaequipajes de arriba y
me pide que le deje pasar a su asiento
de la ventana yo muy exquisita muy
amable le dejo pasar con una sonrisa
elegante
y va y se sienta
se expande tanto que me obliga a mí a
cerrar las piernas y lo que es peor a
renunciar a mi parte del reposabrazos a
mí y entonces pienso vamos a ver
barcelona-valencia tres horas y media
así como que no
pero además caray si es que yo me dedico
a esto si es que estoy cansada ya de
decirle a la gente que es que no hay que
dejarse dominar por los avasalladores
que no se pueden adoptar posturas
contraídas es más si estuviera
analizando esta escena diría que es una
invasión clara del territorio
así que hice lo único que podía hacer en
esa situación
bueno
su brazo rozando mi brazo
su pierna rozando mi pierna hay cosas
que a lo mejor con cuarenta y tantos
pues ya no dan vergüenza pero con
veintipocos pues se ve que sí y entonces
enseguida se contrajo oye tengo que
confesaros que yo me quedé un ratito más
ahí pues oye disfrutando del momento de
hecho probar vosotros a hacerlo venga a
probar esta es la hipoteca perdón está
en la postura
que lo llamamos de la hipoteca pagada
porque es una postura en la que nos
sentimos súper a gusto verdad no la
hagáis en público por favor es demasiado
agresiva demasiado dominante pero en
vuestra casa pues seguramente os hará
sentir mejor
toda esta escena del tren pasó en el más
absoluto de los silencios no hubo
comunicación a través de las palabras
pero os puedo asegurar que quedó todo
dicho al final es que es imposible no
comunicar todo lo que hacemos da
información a los demás todo sobre
nuestra personalidad nuestras emociones
nuestro grupo de pertenencia nuestras
actitudes nuestras motivaciones por
ejemplo voy a pediros un aplauso
muchas gracias estaba nerviosa y me
habéis animado porque he sentido la
aprobación vuestra a través de ese
aplauso los aplausos son gestos y forman
parte de la comunicación no verbal de
hecho a mí muchas veces me dicen ahí
ponerla de los gestos o incluso en
diminutivo que tiene otro matiz a troy
la de los gestos si los gestos son
comunicación no verbal pero yo también
es comunicación no verbal por ejemplo la
forma en la que estáis sentados qué
postura adopta es si miráis o no qué
cara pone jce qué apariencia tenéis o
incluso si habéis llegado media hora
antes de que empezará este evento o ya
habéis entrado tarde todo eso es
comunicación no verbal la comunicación
no verbal es muy amplia y abarcan muchos
canales expresivos que se estudian a
través de investigaciones científicas
esto es ciencia esto no es arte y además
tiene una serie de características entre
ellas la actividad
si yo me callo y vosotros os calláis ya
está como cerró al canal verbal sí pero
es posible cerrar los canales no
verbales de comunicación es posible que
yo deje de emitir y de recibir señales
no verbales
imposible aunque nos quedemos quietos
todo comunica lo que pasa es que
normalmente nos fijamos en aquello que
nos llama la atención o que nos interesa
especialmente pero eso no quiere decir
que el resto de información no esté
presente y lo mejor de todo la estás
decodificando y al decodificar la la
íntegras con información previa que ya
tienes añades tu personalidad añades tus
emociones su cultura tus motivaciones
tus actitudes lo mezclas todavía ni qué
es lo que te sale pues un cóctel de
juicios y pensamientos sobre la otra
persona de cambios de actitud hacia
alguien o hacia una situación o incluso
modificaciones de tu propia conducta
una vez estuve en una fue una
negociación a la que yo iba en clara
desventaja objetiva las personas con las
que me reunía no tenían nada que perder
y yo sí además ellas ejercían cierta
autoridad yo ninguna y para colmo en sus
instalaciones
oye que no es lo mismo que yo vaya a tu
casa que tú vengas a la mía pues yo
llegué con el bolso el maletín el
portátil el móvil la carpeta la libreta
y en la conversación previa antes de
empezar la negociación propiamente dicha
fui dejando los objetos sobre la mesa
y al cabo de 30 segundos en la cabeza de
las personas con las que yo tenía que
negociar su despacho se había convertido
en mi despacho equilibrio un poquito esa
negociación a través de los objetos a
través de esa expansión de los objetos
que ahora que lo pienso lo de la
expansión está de los objetos es
parecido a la expansión del tren me lo
parece a mí tuve un problema de
expansión o da igual lo pienso que me
disperso
lo que os contaba que casi siempre
decodifica mos de forma automática es
decir sin darnos cuenta
por ejemplo cuando llegamos a una
reunión hubo una entrevista de trabajo
la persona que nos recibe
inevitablemente se forma un primer
juicio sobre nosotros una primera
impresión en base a qué
pues entre otras cosas en base a nuestra
apariencia físico y vestimenta por
ejemplo está demostrado que las personas
a las personas con un rostro aniñado es
decir ojos y frente grandes barbilla
redondeada se les atribuyen determinadas
características psicológicas infantiles
como la irresponsabilidad la inmadurez
la incapacidad para tomar decisiones la
vulnerabilidad
esto está demostrado que en los juicios
juega a su favor porque es más fácil que
declaren inocentes a estas personas que
a personas con rasgos faciales maduros
pero también tiene repercusiones en el
ámbito laboral y es que para un puesto
de responsabilidad en igualdad de
condiciones se contrata antes a una
persona con rasgos faciales maduros que
a una persona con rasgos faciales
aniñados evidentemente el nivel de
competencia de una persona no tiene nada
que ver con los rasgos faciales
evidentemente pero lo cierto es que la
competencia es uno de los parámetros
sobre los que nos formamos las primeras
impresiones y en eso la apariencia tiene
mucho que decir
nos formamos primeras impresiones
también en base al olor
cuando saludamos a una persona dándole
dos besos o dándole un abrazo
aprovechamos inconscientemente para oler
a esa persona inconscientemente no nos
damos cuenta pero lo hacemos oye pero y
en ambientes más formales cuando damos
la mano simplemente pues hay una
investigación del 2015 que demostró que
cuando damos la mano a una persona luego
esa mano nos la llevamos a la cara
porque en realidad lo que estamos
haciendo es oler a esa persona a través
del rastro que ha dejado en nuestra
propia mano
nos formamos primeras impresiones
también en base al canal de la ocu
léxica de la mirada hoy es lo mismo
entrar en una tienda o en una oficina y
la persona que está atendiendo nos mira
a la cara nos mira a los ojos que que
esté con la cara metida en su pantalla
de ordenador nos está transmitiendo el
mismo interés no que va
nos formamos también primeras
impresiones en base a la expresión
facial es importantísima la expresión
facial las caras que ponemos es lo mismo
entrar en un despacho con un rostro
afable que con cara de lunes pues no
claro que no
yo soy turista de hotel viajo mucho pero
solo en los hoteles y bueno pues
desviación profesional me fijo mucho los
recepcionistas de hotel
es increíble la correlación que
encuentro entre un recepcionista de
hotel con un rostro afable y una buena
atención al cliente y por el contrario
un recepcionista de hotel con una
expresión más ruda y una mala atención
al cliente
la recepcionista de hotel más sonriente
que he encontrado yo nunca está en
almería
recuerdo que fui a dar un curso iba con
mi marido y mi hija y llegamos ya tarde
llevábamos ya muchas horas de coche
estábamos muy cansados y la verdad es
que no teníamos ganas de nada ni de
hablar ni de cenar ni de sonreír ni de
nada solo queríamos que nos diera la
llave sobre la habitación y estarnos en
la cama pero la recepcionista de hotel
más sonriente que he encontrado yo nunca
mientras gestionaba además muy
eficientemente la reserva no solamente
nos contagió su sonrisa sino que nos
cambió la actitud de hecho luego nos
fuimos por ahí a cenar ojo la actitud
positiva se contagia a través del
comportamiento no verbal por imitación
pero la negativa también cuidado
al día siguiente tuvimos un pequeño
contratiempo en la habitación pequeño
problema y me atendió la misma
recepcionista mi actitud hacia ella a
pesar de que estaba haciendo una
reclamación sobre algo que no estaba
bien era positiva era colaborativa de
oye vamos a solucionar esto evitando el
conflicto porque me caía bien y no
quería estropear eso cuando una persona
nos ha causado una buena primera
impresión luego tendremos tendencia a
ser más indulgentes con sus errores o
con los fallos que pueda tener su
producto o su servicio
y cuánto tiempo tardamos en formarnos
una primera impresión cuánto tiempo
habéis tardado en etiquetarme como
gordita simpática
hace unos años me habréis etiquetado
como atractiva inaccesible pero
las cosas cambian
décimas de segundo en décimas de segundo
con la información que tengamos
disponible nos formamos esa primera
impresión y con esto que os quiero decir
pues que es importantísimo estar atentos
a ese primer momento a esa entrada en
los sitios a ese primer contacto con
otra persona que no conocemos es
importantísimo porque cuando nos
formamos una primera impresión luego va
a ser muy difícil modificarla pero bueno
en una reunión en una entrevista de
trabajo la primera impresión tampoco es
lo único que importa también hay otras
cosas importantes
por ejemplo la escucha saber escuchar
sabemos escuchar
una vez me encontré con una con una
comercial que no paraba de hablar bueno
yo creo que ya habréis notado que yo soy
de esas personas que también les gusta
hablar pues no me dejó meter baza nada y
en un momento de la conversación buena
conversación del monólogo me dice yo es
que no sé qué pasa que no que no caigo
bien a los clientes a mí es que no me
compran
y que esperabas y que esperaba si no
puedes saber lo que quiere el cliente
porque no le dejas decírtelo
si no te conectas con el cliente porque
a nadie le gusta estar de plantón sin
poder hablar
si en realidad lo que estás haciendo ahí
es valorar más lo que tú tienes que
decir que lo que te tiene que decir la
otra persona como esperas vender algo
así para esto no se lo dije esto lo
pensé ya está evidentemente bien a
escuchar de verdad
no es estar simplemente callado y
esperar a que la otra persona acabe de
hablar mientras yo ya tengo mi respuesta
preparada cuidado escuchar de verdad es
estar ahí con la mente en blanco y
prestar plena atención a las palabras
que dice la otra persona la comunicación
verbal es prestar atención a como dice
esas palabras la comunicación no verbal
pero también es hacer ver a la otra
persona que le estoy escuchando en esto
de la escucha tan importante ser como
parecer no solamente escuchar sino
también hacer ver que escucho cuando
hago contacto visual es decir ojos a
ojos con la otra persona le estoy dando
la importancia suficiente como para que
esa persona quiera seguir hablando
y cuando hago este simple gesto de
asentimiento de vez en cuando le estoy
dando permiso para que siga hablando y
además siempre con el cuerpo enfocado
hacia la otra persona muy importante
además de la escucha también es
importante saber adaptarse a la otra
persona
una vez fui a la oficina donde tengo la
cuenta del banco a ver unas opciones de
renting para un coche
yo creo que habréis notado que hablo
rápido verdad hoy me estoy conteniendo
de que de normal abro mucho más rápido
pues el gestor bancario que me atendió
hablaba tremendamente lento
yo al cabo de los dos minutos yo creo
que envejece como dos años porque me
aburrí me bloqueé y por supuesto no
contraté nada es importante adaptarse a
la otra persona a través del
comportamiento no verbal porque al menos
en el corto plazo todos congeniamos más
con personas que se parecen a nosotros y
me he dejado lo más importante para el
final la congruencia que importante ser
congruentes qué importante es estar
alineados con nuestros valores con
nuestros pensamientos si finges que eres
alguien que en realidad no eres si
finges que tu producto es el mejor
aunque sepas que no lo es
si finges que crees en algo lo que en
realidad no cree es tu comportamiento no
verbal que delatara
una vez me contrataron en una empresa
para dar formación a sus comerciales
comunicación no verbal aplicada a las
ventas
hablando con los comerciales me di
cuenta que el problema que tenían era un
problema de incongruencia era un
problema de que no creían en su producto
que sabían que estaban vendiendo una
cabra y eso les generaba un malestar y
un conflicto interno es tremendo
qué importante ser congruentes
importantes
estar alineados con nuestros
pensamientos con nuestros sentimientos
al final que importante es ser
conscientes de que todo lo que hacemos
comunica es imposible no comunicar así
que recuerdan presta atención a la
primera impresión acuérdate de esa
recepcionista de almería escucha de
verdad adapta te al cliente no hagas
como el gestor de mi banco se congruente
siempre pero sobre todo sobre todo no
dejes que te quiten el sitio del tren
[Aplausos]